back our first speaker in the afternoon
I hope you're all not asleep after lunch
at an espresso or something otherwise
subabata will wake us up about meanfield
approximations for high dimensional
patient regression
thank you so much for the invitation to
speak
um I've been visiting for a while and it
has been extremely stimulating to be
here and to interact with everyone
um so I'll talk about uh some recent
work on using main field approximations
to understand uh the posterior
distribution in high dimensional
Bayesian regression uh this is based on
joint work with schumach who is in the
audience here today
um and
so the connecting theme with this
Workshop is that graphons will come up
at some point we'll have to wait a bit
but they'll come up eventually
um but I think
um one aspect that could be interesting
to the audience here is that we try to
use this framework of graph fonts to
understand some high dimensional
probability distributions that are
sort of of main interest and I think the
disconnection is is kind of interesting
to me so maybe it'll spark some
conversations in this
um intersection here
okay so I I I'll try to set everything
up from scratch as I go along and won't
assume any background regarding Bayesian
statistics or the results in the area
and if there are any questions please
feel free to just stop me and ask me
questions
okay so the general setup for Bayesian
inference is that You Know You observe
some data D coming from some parametric
family of distribution speed Theta
um Theta throughout this talk is some
um you know Vector valued parameter in P
dimensions and this is what you know you
would really like to learn from the data
so under the Bayesian approach you
assume some prior on the parameter this
reflects your measure of uncertainty
um you construct the posterior
distribution
and then under the vision framework you
carry out inference based on this
posterior distribution in principle it's
it's straightforward but there are of
course
um two main questions in this in you
know operationalizing this approach of
course from a theoretical perspective
you want to understand what are the
properties of these posterior
distributions and this is uh this is
quite challenging especially when the
parameter space is quite large so in
high Dimensions this is a challenging
question
and then there is uh another very
central question which is okay even if
you have some control on the posterior
distribution how do you actually work
with it right so how do you approximate
the posterior distribution
now uh the most common method in
answering this second question are mcmc
algorithms where you try to sample
um from these high dimensional
distributions by running an appropriate
Markov chain
um but I actually will not talk about
mcmc methods today instead I'll talk
about this alternative approach of
variational approximations that
has you know very old roots but has been
becoming increasingly popular in
statistics and machine learning because
it provides
um
computational get you know it's it's
computationally very efficient
um so what is this approach
um at a very high level the idea is as
follows you have some posterior
distribution P Theta given X you would
like to approximate this so you say okay
what I will do is that I'll approximate
this distribution
using a distribution Q of theta from
some class of distributions right that's
the approach I'll get this good
approximation by minimizing the KL
Divergence
and
um essentially what this does is that it
converts this problem of sampling to one
of optimization although you do this on
the space of probability distributions
and depending on what class of
distributions you take here in some
cases this optimization is fairly
explicitor you can get some control on
it right the most popular choice for
this family of approximating
um distributions is the class of product
measures and uh we'll refer to this as
the naive main field approximation this
is sort of the first thing that you try
um and you can do more sophisticated
things but as a first step what this is
doing is that it neglects the
dependencies among the coordinates in
your distribution and tries to get the
sort of the best product measure sorry I
might be confused why do you write Q of
theta yeah I think that's a typo I think
it's just key okay yeah thank you
I've Got The Power of HSC but yes it
does have to be smooth so but I use the
even digits or something yeah
right of course I mean whenever you have
to make sense of you know whether this
works or not you naturally have to make
assumptions on your telemetric family so
today I'll just talk about linear
regression where everything is very
explicit but if one has to make sense of
this then of course you'll need
smoothness in the parameter and things
like that so those will naturally come
but this is sort of just things that are
very hard
thanks
okay so
when you look at this the first question
you think of is that okay when is this
something reasonable to do like is it is
it meaningful at all to do this
approximation when will it give you some
guarantees and this will form one of the
main questions for us today
now
I think okay this is my understanding of
of the
um evolution of this line of research in
statistics
so I think the way we have tried to
address this question in statistics and
machine learning is to say well we'll
understand it in two steps we'll first
develop methods to understand the
posterior distribution itself and then
once we understand properties of the
posterior distribution we'll ask the
follow-up question is the naive mean
field approximation accurate for that
right and so we have kind of broken it
down into this two-step approach that
has been the typical approach
what we will talk about today kind of
flips this perspective a bit but I'll
come to that in a moment okay but first
I think let's talk about the traditional
approach that I want to understand
when is naive meanfield sort of the kind
of reasonably accurate and that will
depend on first understanding the
behavior of the posterior distribution
so what happens generally
so the classical picture on this is
fairly well understood and this is under
the kind of smoothness assumptions that
Christian alluded to so kind of what is
understood here here is my schematic
picture so here what I have sort of this
entire parameter space suppose you have
data that is being drawn from one
particular parametric distribution that
is indicated by this red dot here and
it's kind of well understood that if you
have a reasonable prior then your
posterior essentially puts most of its
mass on a ball of radius one over square
root n around the data generating truth
right
um and this is all in this classical
asymptotic regime where the dimension of
your parameter space p is fixed and the
number of data points n actually
diverges often
the classical asymptotic regime
and it's actually been proved
um quite recently that at least in this
classical regime if you do the naive
mean field approximation it also has
fairly nice behavior so under the
smoothness kind of conditions it will
put most of its mass on a ball of radius
1 over n maybe at the level of constants
you'll have a slightly inflated radius
but other than that in terms of rates
here okay
so at least in this case
um we understand the behavior of the
posterior and we understand that the
ninth mean field is reasonably accurate
things are okay
so what happens in high Dimensions right
that's sort of one of the
interesting questions in in modern
statistics and machine learning because
you
always run into data sets that are high
dimensional
and the answer is that over the past
decade there has been sort of of
quite a lot of work in this area and the
punch line in some sense is that there
is a morally similar story that has
emerged
under additional structural assumptions
on the underlying data generating
mechanism
okay
so the one of the
canonical stories in this regard is if
you assume that you have some data
generating truth P of theta naught where
the vector Theta naught itself has some
structure for example it might be sparse
okay and under these kind of sparsity
assumptions you have a similar story
that has started to emerge you still
have your parameter space you have some
data generating true and you have your
posterior distribution but now okay
depending on
um the complexity of the problem
depending on the rate of growth of your
parameter space and your data generating
distribution
um your posterior is still kind of
supported on a ball of shrinking radius
but this radius size might not be 1 over
210
and that would be essentially I mean
there is some information theoretic
bottleneck here and in many cases now
people understand you know what are
conditions or the problems so that this
Epsilon n is essentially the information
theoretically optimal rate
of cases we understand this
Okay so
what I want to do today is to go beyond
this regime so I kind of want to push
Beyond this and I want to ask the
question okay
yes
go back to the previous pictures this is
now not for the Midfield approximation I
just bought it Australia yes yes yes
right okay I should also say but in the
past one or two years there has also
been follow-up work in exploring the
behavior of the mean field approximation
in these regions especially for these
parts models and it's kind of understood
that on depending on the complexity of
your parameter space there are
conditions where it's still accurate so
it puts most of its muscle and Wall of
previous order Epsilon n there are also
conditions that have you know some
examples that have been identified where
the Management Field will actually you
know put its mass on a ball of shrinking
radius but we didn't figure it them
Epsilon so it might not be optimal in
terms of the way but there have been
investigations in this direction but
kind of I think one
um ingredient that has kind of been very
very crucial in all of these
investigations is the a priority fact
that the posterior is actually
Contracting to the data generating that
has kind of the universal environments
investigations
so and that's sort of what I want to
push Beyond a bit today so what I really
want to talk about is a simple example
where
you have your posterior distribution
that still contains a lot of statistical
information about the data generating
mechanism but your posterior doesn't
really contract to the truth because you
simply don't have you know enough signal
it's still it's not non-trivial but it's
not enough that you can kind of
overwhelm the noise and contract to the
truth
and I'll start with this sort of very
canonical example or you know very very
simple example that at least to us seems
like a good starting point
um so I'll talk about linear regression
so the setup here is that you have data
y i x i
um your responses are real value
um your features are P dimensional
and to fit the model you assume a linear
model so you fit the model Y equals X
beta plus error and we assume just that
um I have a product prior on the
coordinates so each so I assume that
each beta I is IID from some prior
um for Simplicity I'll assume that this
variance Sigma squared is known
throughout
um in practice people put additional
priors on Sigma squared or estimated
and I have some technical constraint
that I'll assume that my prior is on a
bounded set but I think one can go
beyond this if you have like additional
kind of tail conditions on the prior so
maybe sub gaussian is possible but for
the moment I'll just restrict to a
bounded said
now I should make a remark here that
throughout this at least till the very
end of the talk
I am not going to assume that this is
truly the data generating mechanism this
is really the model that is used by the
statistician to fit the data I am not
assuming this is the right data
generating mechanism that will come
later I'll make that assumption but at
some later point
any questions regarding the setup
oh so I just mean that okay this just
rules out some
I mean sort of weirdness things where
you know you can consider your
priorities on minus one one but it's
basically supported on minus half half
no no no I'm just saying that this is
like the real support it's not like so
if I have a tiny absolutely a minus one
and plus one at otherwise
yeah that's that's still that's true
yeah that's just a technical report
foreign
I'll talk about random designs later but
I I want to really think about these as
fixed designs and I'll talk about you
know what properties do I need on the
design to understand the question
whenever I assume sort of random designs
we will I'll talk about properties
holding almost surely
okay so now now comes the question of
okay what what did I mean when I sort of
say that okay I want to go to a regime
where there is no contraction I don't
have enough signal I kind of mentioned
these things informally so let me try to
make this a bit more formal
um I'll assume that both the number of
data points n and the demand and the
dimension of the features grow to
Infinity I'll talk about the relative
rates of what I need later
so this is not specifically the
assumption that I'll be making but I
think this kind of makes it makes a
point so to kind of think of what regime
I'm interested in you can kind of
Imagine a setting where your sample
covariance Matrix has order one operator
now
that's kind of one example to think of
I'll kind of weaken this assumption
eventually but this is a good starting
point
why do I want to think of this
particular regime and why do I think of
this as a low SNR regime so for example
if you look at let's say the usual
ordinary least squares estimate it has a
covariance matrix that's proportional to
x-transpose X inverse right so for
example if x transpose X is operator
Norm that is of order one then if you
look at individual coordinates then its
variances are of order one so in this
case it's not like the entire posterior
is collapsing your covariance Matrix is
something of order one and this is sort
of the the regime that I sort of will be
thinking about I'll make assumptions on
The covariance Matrix eventually that
are of this flavor they will be weaker
than this but this will always be a
sufficient condition
and
there were I mean in this regime you
can't really recover your P dimensional
parameter consistently but you can still
carry out non-trivial
inputs right so the schematic
to think about here is that you have
your high dimensional parameter space
you have some data generating mechanism
maybe but when you construct your
posterior your probability distribution
is diffuse over the entire parameter
space
um but it's not like it's uniform it's
still kind of peaked around the truth
and you kind of still want to understand
yeah
that's that's kind of what I want to do
it and and the fact that you know you
have this entire diffuse distribution is
kind of an effect of the fight between
um the dimensionality of your parameter
space and the number of data points you
have things are kind of exactly balanced
Okay so
here comes the first question right so
if if you still want to kind of follow
the the approach that I outlined before
you'll first say okay I first need to
understand the behavior of the posterior
distribution and then maybe as a
follow-up I'll ask you what is the
behavior of the human field is it a good
approximation and things like that
but this is where I will flip the
perspective
in reality we don't really or okay this
is my understanding that so far the
tools that we had to understand these
posterior distributions They Don't
Really generalize to a setting where you
don't have this contraction or where you
don't expect this contraction and
instead we'll basically say that we'll
flip the perspective and understand the
posterior distribution itself
by using the mean field approximation
so the approach that we'll adopt is that
you know we'll we'll develop some
sufficient conditions so we'll carve out
a set of examples where the mean field
approximation is actually accurate
and then we'll use this mean field
approximation to say something about the
posterior
that's kind of what we'll do
um and I I showed that a priori say that
you know this idea of using the mean
field approximation to understand High
dimensional distributions this we are
not initiating this approach this has
started recently a lot in in the area of
non-linear large deviations over the
past
um seven eight years now
um
there has been a lot of focus on using
this approach to understand questions in
uh for large deviations of subgraph
counts on random graphs also in
understanding statistical physics models
um so our
approach here is kind of in the second
spirit so we are thinking of these high
dimensional posteriors as sort of models
coming from statistical physics and we
are kind of using the mean field
approximation just to understand that
that's kind of the way we get this
Okay so
before I I go on
um I should formalize what I mean when I
say that the mean field approximation is
accurate for the posterior right what do
I mean by that so your posterior
distribution is a probability
distribution in P dimensions and things
are you know every coordinate has
ordered one fluctuations so typically if
you look at the KL Divergence that will
be of order p
so we'll say that this naive mean field
is actually correct to Leading order if
this infimum is actually little open
this is precisely what I will mean
um through the subsequent discussion
whenever I say that okay
you know this discrepancies you know the
mean field is actually a good
approximation
so what I will mean throughout is that
there is some queue some sequence of
cues such that the scale Divergence is
okay so these are the following things
that I want to talk about
um
so when is it accurate
it is not always accurate but we'll
Identify some set of sufficient
conditions
um under which
this will be good to the leading order
and I'll try to parse this condition
more in the context of random designs
um there is a follow-up question that
okay if this is a good accurate
approximation can it give you
information about the actual posterior
distribution and this is where we'll see
graphons can be actually useful so
coming back to the theme of this
Workshop
and okay I don't think I'll get to the
last part of the talk uh which is okay
what happens if the naive mean field is
actually inaccurate
um what can you do so it turns out that
there are more advanced mean field
approximations that might be better in
those settings I probably might get to
it just or might not but I'm also happy
to talk about that offline but these are
essentially the the directions that we
are interested in
okay so let's let's jump into the first
question right so what are conditions on
the design
that will guarantee that the naive mean
field approximation is accurate to
Leading order for the actual posterior
so to formalize this I'll be to talk
about the normalizing constant of the
distribution or in in statistical
physics terminology this would be the
partition function for the model right
so this is just exactly you write down
what the posterior distribution is
um and you integrate it over the prior
this is just an unusual normalizing
constant nothing new Happening Here the
only thing that I did here this turns
out to be useful is that I had this this
is a quadratic form originally in the
sample covariance Matrix I zeroed out
the diagonals and I absorbed these terms
into the prior so I kind of tilt it but
other than that nothing happened but the
prior is not just
the prior
uh is sorry so
Australia is just one you could have
different pie eyes we could have handled
that we considered the case where every
pie was the same but a priority even if
you had different Pi eyes the results
would go through
Okay so
this is just released so the reason why
I introduce
um the the normalizing constant or the
partition function is that there is a
very clear connection between the
partition function and the accuracy of
the naive mean field approximation and
this is again not some this is this is
direct this is just some algebra once we
write out what the KL Divergence is okay
but before I get there I should I should
recount this uh well-known fact
essentially from convex analysis which
says that if you look at the log
normalizing constant for this model it
essentially has this variational
representation and this is essentially
convex duality in this case of
exponential families right
and if you write down what the scale
Divergence is explicitly it turns out
that you know rephrased in terms of the
partition function this basically says
that this log of zp must have this
approximation
okay
so I did some algebra here but this is
um directly just right writing down what
the scale Divergence is so the reason
why I put these two expressions here is
is to just develop some intuition for
this so generally I know that this log
zp is can be expressed as the supremum
so if I restrict the supremum to the set
of all product distributions I always
get a lower bound
what this is saying is that effectively
the the difference between you know the
two sides of the bound is essentially
something little of
so this is precisely the condition under
which the naive Bean field is inaccurate
okay so here is here is our result
um the first result in this direction
which says that okay
recall what this Matrix a was The Matrix
a is the sample covariance Matrix in
your design with the diagonals all
zeroed out that's what it is so it's a
symmetric Matrix P by P
so I make this assumption this is kind
of the trivial assumption this is
essentially sort of like saying that the
Matrix a has operator Norm of order one
but this is not the L2 operator Norm
this is sort of like the L Infinity to
L1 operator now
and so I I want that to be ordered P
that's basically just saying that I am
in this low s analogy that's my scaling
assumption that is not really an
assumption about the design
the non-trivial Assumption here is
essentially this condition that trace of
a squared is little o of P
right so essentially as soon as you have
this condition on the design it
essentially tells you that the 19 field
approximation is accurate to Leading
order
okay so what does this assumption mean
so if you look at trace of a squared
um this is the sum of squared
eigenvalues of the symmetric P by P
Matrix so it has operator Norm of order
one roughly so it's leading eigenvalue
you can think is basically order one so
what this is saying is that it has
little op many eigenvalues that are of
order one
so roughly there are little op many
order one eigenvalues then everything
kind of decays very fast
so this is one set of conditions
under which we can prove that the
uh 19 field approximation is accurate to
Leading on
any questions on the result
okay so before I I proceed
um I should make some remarks about
where this comes from so we use this
Machinery of non-linear large deviations
that were started in the work of
Chatterjee and demo followed upon by Yan
and many other people now
they used this approach before to
understand
um easing models on sequences of graphs
and our application in this particular
case is similar to that so just this
result by itself is not very different
from what had existed in the literature
before and it essentially just stems
from the fact that we are looking at a
distribution that has pairwise
interactions so as long as it's pairwise
interactions you don't really care if
it's if the individual variables are you
know plus minus one or if they are in
some bounded set you don't really care
so just this result by itself is not
that far removed from what had existed
prior to our work I think the main
contribution for these results is to say
that you can now take this approximation
and actually say something about the
posterior distribution so what I'll tell
you henceforth is I think our main
contribution
but before I proceed maybe let me pause
for a second to see if there are any
questions just about response
so I'm exactly proving this right so
this is this essentially is from this
rephrasing right so this is this
condition is when it is correct in
reading order right you will prove that
right I will prove that this happens if
and only if this happens right and and
so they're equivalent and also I'll
prove that this thing is true under a
sufficient set of conditions so this is
not necessarily insufficient but this is
only one set of sufficient conditions
under which this will be
questions
okay but now you can ask me this
question okay
is your condition in good maybe you're
just covering only a small part of this
set of examples that exist out there
right
so actually we have some understanding
that there is some sense in which this
set of conditions is
nearly optimal in some sense so in
particular if you look at the case of
random designs so if you look at an
example where every row is IID
from a mean zero gaussian distribution
with some covariance Matrix gamma of P
we have you know whatever conditions we
had trace of a squared Little P this
translates into a condition on the
population covariance Matrix such that
you have accuracy of naive mean field
and this essentially tells you that if
you have an IID gaussian design for
example
then naive mean field is accurate to
Leading order only if p is little low n
and there are results from statistical
physics that suggest and now we have
some proofs of that as well that if p
and N are actually growing proportional
to each other then naive we field is not
accurate you need more complicate or
more advanced approximations uh such as
the the beta approximation of the tap
approximation which will be correct so
in some sense there are some classes of
examples where these this is kind of
giving you the optimal condition right
so Kendrick for gaussian designs it can
recover this P equals little o n
condition which we believe is kind of
optimal
questions
okay so let me skip over this example
there is another example we had of like
a IID Bernoulli design and we can
identify some set of parameter regimes
where this is correct but this is
similar so let me skip this
so
coming to sort of the the main
set of new contributions I feel which is
okay you have this accuracy of naive
mean field
is it any good from a statistical
perspective does it actually shed
you know does it actually give you some
new information regarding the behavior
of the posterior distribution as a whole
Okay so
at a high level my answer will be yes in
certain cases but let me expand more on
them right so you will need some
additional conditions under which you
can say what things will
um
now okay there's I have put in a lot of
notation here but I don't want you to
look at it
um this is no good I'll try to tell you
what the punch line is
um but before I do that maybe let me
make a remark about
um easing models on complete graphs or
Curie wise models for for people in the
audience who might know this example so
for example in the if you look at the
query Weiss model then it is well
understood that naive mean field is
accurate in this case but if you look at
the low temperature behavior of the
query wise model for example then you
have two of these phases that exist
right you can have coordinates roughly
like plus M Star the other ones having a
minus M star kind of bias right
um and if those are the examples that
you have then
okay in that particular case you can
identify that it's a mixture
but generally you can have many of these
phases that can coexist and so
extracting information out of that
becomes a bit challenging
so what I'll describe in the next few
slides is our further sufficient
conditions under which you just have one
dominant phase so that you can actually
extract information out of it this is
kind of the simplest thing you can do
um
and you can definitely push this forward
but this is just to illustrate that
there are conditions under which you can
extract information
and in case this example was unfamiliar
please feel free to ignore my remark so
let me let me
know
your results will hold in the high
temperature no no the 10th the result
holds at any temperature the point is
that in certain cases like the QV device
example at low temperature you can have
multiple Seasons right and so in more
General complicated examples your number
of phases could be pretty large they
could in fact be like e to the Little P
many phrases so in those complicated
examples it's difficult to derive the
properties of the distribution using the
mean field approximation
so what I'll do is that I'll avoid that
issue altogether and I'll identify
further conditions
such as the high temperature phase under
which there is one dominant
phase and using that phase I will get
some information about the possible for
me what's going to be as a physical I
would call that a heart attack so you
have you will have one dominant face
yeah and then you can then I can extract
information so it turns out I mean from
a purely statistical perspective I think
it can it still shed some information
because
among the conditions that I'll talk
about you can have high temperature
conditions but you can also put in
conditions on the prior
which will still govern you know which
says that the model is basically at high
temperature in energy so for example
Sumit has follow-up work
um with other colleagues uh where they
show that if the prior is long concave
it's always fun there's always one
dominant phase yeah
I'm not sure I understand why having
multiple faces
best
yes
it's still true but it's just that
because we are only looking at things at
the resolution of little op it's exactly
as you say you can have eatable little
opinion
phases and so kind of match like extract
so I think things can still be done
non-asympotically but kind of taking
limits out of that turns out to be a bit
more hair so I agree that it's
definitely possible to go beyond what
I'll describe here
um but kind of going to the most general
setting I still think
[Music]
right so the punch line is that for this
very special case of linear regression
there is something special that happens
for any product measure that is an
Optimizer you can basically prove that
the coordinates can just be quadratic
tilts of the product that's special
about the linear regression case and
once you know that you can identify sort
of what are these parameters you know
gamma 1i and Gamma 2i that give you the
optimizers so what the main punch line
that I would like to kind of um
I would like you to take away from this
slide is that for this very special case
of linear regression with product priors
you can convert this optimization
problem over probability measures to a
scalar optimization problem and that
this is special about linear regression
you can do this and essentially it comes
down to a
a still a high dimensional
optimization problem this is generally
non-convex
but uh at least it's a scale out problem
not on the space of probability
distributions
that's kind of the big takeaway from the
slide
and okay so this is what I meant
formally you know when I was talking
about this one unique phase kind of
thing the point is if you now look at
this optimization problem if it happens
that you have some you hacked such that
if you move away from U Hat by distance
order P then the optimization the
optimized value essentially falls off
from the global Optimum then this point
you had essentially determines the
properties of the of a sample drawn from
this distribution
so let me parse that a bit more so
suppose you have this condition right
and you have some U hat which satisfies
this condition
then if you draw
a sample beta I from the posterior
distribution and if you look at
properties at the scale of law of large
numbers then you can describe it
essentially in terms of this U hat
there is an explicit set of
distributions that you can derive out
that you had which essentially tell you
the law of large numbers type properties
for samples drawn from the posterior
distribution
says yeah so
this is the condition
so the condition essentially is that you
have some U hack here so that if you
move away from the U hack then the value
essentially falls off
it doesn't really say that I'm not
assuming that there is one global map
like there is only one like I'm not
assuming it's this function is convex or
energy or convex or concave it can have
different local optimizers that's fine
but in some sense I'm just assuming
there is one roughly unique dominant
Global optimize
yes oh five yes I will wrap up
um
Okay so
as promised let me okay so there are
some conditions which I I kind of
mentioned so if you have this is sort of
a high temperature kind of condition on
the model which governs there is one
unique phase you can put in some
conditions on the prior as well I'll
skip over this for the time being but
um you can interpret these conditions
and these tell you
you know these are conditions under
which you have one dominant phase
but okay let me talk about graphones
because this is a workshop on graph
limits and and I want to kind of convey
how these can be useful in understanding
these posterior distributions so so far
in whatever I have done I have
stayed away from making assumptions on
the true data generating distribution
right I've worked under a case where Y
and X are given to me and I work with
them
but if you look at the literature on
Beijing statistics uh the the de facto
approach is to assume that there is some
underlying model
which can be different from the model
that you fit
but then you try to see how much of the
truth you recover
so that's kind of the usual approach you
assume that there is some model which
generates the data as the statistician
you don't quite know what that model is
you fit something else
and then you want to know okay how do I
do
so I want to kind of take a step now
towards this approach and and see what
what this set of tools can actually tell
us about this particular setting
um so okay so what I'll let me okay so I
have some stuff on graphones I think
this is very well known to the audience
here uh we saw some of this in the
earlier talks today so I'll skip over
this and I'll just talk about this one
result
so what this is is that now suppose your
data is actually generated from a true
linear model with mean X beta naught
right
um I'm not assuming that the coordinates
of beta not our IID or something this is
just some Vector sequence of vector
space or not
I'll make now assumptions on the
convergences of these um of my problem
parameters okay so in particular I'll
assume that if you look at the sequence
of matrices PP recall that this is just
the sample covariance Matrix with the
diagonal zeroed out
blown up by P this converges under a
strong cut metric to some limiting graph
on W
um and I have you know L1 convergences
for other functions this this is
precisely what you'd expect then under
this mean field sort of assumption I can
actually State a limiting variational
problem for my log partition function or
for my mean field approximation to it
um this is sort of the main punch line
and then what this okay I have some
description for this limiting functional
I have some interpretation for that but
I'll I don't think I'll have time to
actually parse this
so there is some explicit form for what
this functional is
but what is nice here and this is kind
of what I want to draw your attention to
is that
under these conditions you have some
unique optimizer
this unique Optimizer has a fixed Point
description
and this essentially governs law of
large number type properties for samples
drawn from the posterior distribution
so this is sort of where this limiting
description turns out to be useful for
us and I think this is what connects it
to the themes of this Workshop
so okay so I had some other things that
I'll skip over to keep to not go over
the allotted time uh okay so takeaway
essentially is that we can use this
theory of non-linear deviations to
actually justify using naive mean field
approximations they can tell us about
high dimensional Bayesian posteriors
um I had some stuff later but I didn't
get into that there are some follow-up
directions but I'm happy to talk about
it more often thank you so much for your
attention
[Applause]
foreign
well understood that the mean field
approximation is is far easy to compute
in high dimension as well right so if
you are in in like these high
temperatures sort of regimes then you
actually have sort of global convexity
and things are nice
turns out there are similar conditions
actually even under these conditions on
the prior that I sort of described
so there is a result that Freddy Kohler
has from a few years ago that is
actually very interesting where he says
that for ferromagnetic easing models if
you start from the all once
configuration you will get always to a
near Optima for the naive mean field
irrespective of whether there is a
unique phase or not
but we didn't make any such
ferromagnetic assumption in the model so
it's so in the case where you're away
from these assumptions is generally
non-convex so without additional
assumptions on the design it could be
hard
okay send offers a question maybe we can
start with Julia
foreign
thank you very much for the organizers
for inviting me to this Workshop it's
been very enjoyable so far